marco m bari e welcome to this dio è
pseudo dai ai stavo controllando tutti i
video fatti di delle robe giapponesi in
occhio fatto finale sono arrivati
all'episodio 7 io ho fatto sette video
reactions pubblicità giapponesi il
problema è che posso arrivare anche a
100 cioè possono sparare con i direttivi
se non sto scherzando io amo il giappone
cioè per me io io potrei reagire anche
un palo della luce giapponese a tutto il
giorno 6 milioni di iscritti lo facciamo
il segno di iscritti relazione a un palo
giappone come sempre devo tentare di
indovinare di che pubblicità si tratta
prima che finisca stampante alla stampa
resta fante per squali non usare
l'inchiostro di squalo per stampare le
foto
no ai fori into non ho capito perchè
perchè dello squalo ma fa niente piselli
nel senso di ortaggio tanto che la donna
aveva una mascotte inguardabile questa
insomma con tutto sto gatto ragazzi
ma che se stesso ma perché c'è un gap
andava scusatemi fatemi capire ma cosa
sto guardando questa è una pubblicità
del gas
c'è scritto tokyo gas fidatevi che la
pubblicità dei gas e ne farm sicuro
guarda guarda guarda varda sicuro c'è la
combustione ed io non so andiamo avanti
ragazzi bellissimo per adesso il pre
pisodio partito meglio forse va bene ho
già intravede un tizio con la faccia
tamburo quindi perfetto io non so cosa
sta vedendo ragazzi vi rendete conto che
quando qualcuno gli sto schiaffeggia
crea un no un pezzo musicale anche
abbastanza recente forze scusami che non
ho capito un segnetto alla fine cadde so
resort ok pubblicità dei tamburi non so
cosa fosse non lo vogliono anche se ce
la fate non mettere un personaggio
carino in tutte le pubblicità vi prego
dove sono gli zombie dov'è il sangue era
tutti cose carine che va bene per carità
però avevo uscirebbero gli arcobaleni
dalle orecchie dopo due minuti di
pubblicità però che se vi immaginate
dopo sanremo dopo sanremo far partire se
pubblicità fermi che è partita una roba
che mi interessano
[Musica]
questa animal crossing yu lik quindi è
vecchia st pubblicità poi che uscito
mille anni fa 2012 almeno si
[Musica]
ragazzi appena uscirà il nuovo animal
crossing vi vedrete fare 860.000
gameplay e non me ne frega niente se ciò
24 anni e sono maschio me ne sbatto ok
ok c'è un porco gigante che fa la
pubblicità della farm e tu stai
pubblicizzando i tuoi parenti morti
morti li stai pubblicità liste tu sei un
fottutissimo cannibale
renditi conto di quello che stai facendo
e come se cucina sera gli esseri umani
come se andassi a fare la pubblicità
mangiate gli esseri umani come me questo
è sicuramente non è legale però andiamo
avanti
oddio la bambina delle caramelle
caramelle caramelle lo so perché l'ho
mangiato un sacco queste caramelle gocce
st mascotte lista bambina con le guance
così ho capito una parola finalmente
[Musica]
sì ma basta fatemi vedere qualcosa cosa
sto guardando come avete letto cosa cioè
il consiglio con chi il cac saito picco
si sa mai cosa che cazzo è successo
c'era vittime ma cosa fai
cos'è sta roba cosa mi stai pubblici
cosa così era sta cosa spiega che poi
otto ore per fare io non lo so ragazzini
avanti one piece
anzi no no fullmetal alchemist fashion
wonderland o negozio di vestiti
giustamente pubblicizziamo lo così non
so vabbè burrocacao freestyle burro
cacao o mio dio
[Musica]
bellissime la colonna sonora complimenti
ragazzi
[Musica]
oggi
professore nei caffè questa musica
ma cos'è ma cosa ma perché sul sì va beh
ragazzi state calmi vi prego fatemi una
tisana per cortesia la birra per gatti
chiaro 100 scatti chance counter vari è
ovvio quest'ultimo frame
vi prego lo voglio come sfondo mi screen
questo video e lo voglio come sfondo del
telefono chiunque sbloccherà il mio
telefono dovrà chiedermi ma cosa strana
messo come sponda io non saprò cosa
rispondergli la mamma che stanca i
bambini la pizza felicità della pizza
pizza per bambini pizza hut redeye più o
meno
mamma mia che schifo voglio morire
adesso i cdo prendimi cos'è sta ma cos'è
dai ragazzi vi prego bamba male anche se
mi imputano la pistola in testa o vado a
mangiare la pizza premier
[Musica]
sì dài sta tirando calci al pallone cosa
sta succedendo laser bim paralleli che
lì sono giappone tra cui la madonna cosa
mi rappresenta
stare seduti sul niente ok l'altro come
hanno fatto possono baciare una sedia in
green screen e bravia engine kakà credo
non ho capito però
cos'è
[Musica]
cos'è sta roba grana roma è un caffè ok
caffè latino voi scherzate ma sta roba a
me veramente successo in giappone e non
sto scherzando che è l'uomo che è uomo
ma cosa vuol dire più cosa gli
appartamenti era immobiliare vogue con
l'ombrello che vabbè dai questa penso
sia della strike non ne sono sicuro ok a
secondo me la stanno facendo passare
come se in realtà la gente non sapesse
cosa sta succedendo ma è realtà secondo
me lo sapevano tutti però va bene c'è
loro ordinano la sprite poi si bagnano
ovviamente poca all'aria sprite o a
proposito ragazzi del mio viaggio in
giappone come ho fatto dei prima un
ombrello è io nel quando sono stati in
giappone ho fatto un tot di storie sul
mio instagram che non so se qualcuno
seguitemi su instagram maledizione gli
faccio vedere
che partita musica di scordato online a
premessa io vi faccio vedere un paio di
cose carine che ho visto in giappone nel
caso non avesse visto sta roba
allora cui eravamo arrivati a tokyo il
primo giorno poi vabbè non è andato con
jean che
d'andrea che ci faceva ridere che la
headline si chiamasse vedo queste rame
il modo pazzo personam e non lo sapete
se avessi meno problemi voi scherza
allora partiamo dal presupposto che
comunque ero jet lag ato io ragazzi
quando sono oggetto legato non so
neanche come mi chiama allora io ho un
problema della mia vita sono peak due
problemi sono dei problemi
quattro sono mag lotirchio pigro e
quando sonno io non vivo e come se il
mio cervello fosse un nokia colonico di
vecchi 5300 più o meno con la batteria
però dell'iphone ecco quello è quindi il
discorso è che non so neanche mangiare
senza sbrodolare mi quando lasciamo
perdere tokyo tower quest arabi ragazzi
vi prego dati già po andate in giappone
guarda squadra mista a roma c'era la
nebbia già niente peccato perché era un
giorno di nebbia per perché dalla tokyo
tower si vede non tutto a tokyo perché è
enorme ma gran parte di totti ed è
infinita infinita quando si vede niente
perché c'è la nebbia purtroppo dove
visse piaciuto ragazzi questa era la
ricciola le cose giapponesi anche un po
di storie già che c'ero iscrivetevi al
canale e fatemi sapere se volete un blog
bridge perché l'ultima volta hanno fatto
quello che ho fatto solo storie fatemi
sapere se vorreste un blog proprio
dedicato al giappone quando vado in
giappone quando andrò in giappone perché
non so quanto quando tornerò esattamente
mi saranno prossimo comunque sì
sicuramente
spero che vi sia piaciuto iscritti al
canale schiacciata la campanellina
presso la giornata i suoi video che
escono e noi come sempre ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]